مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا وشكرا لك ليلى نافذتنا
للتحليل العسكري اليوم ستكون لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وتقييما لا اكثر من
90 يوما من هذه الحرب بمراحل مختلفه
سنستضيف كالعاده المحلل العسكري اللواء
فايز الدويري لكن في البدايه سنتابع ما
الذي يحصل ميدانيا على الارض من خلال
الخريطه التفاعليه التي اعدتها لنا
الزميله سلام خضر تفضلي سلام شكرا حسن
التطورات متسارعه ومستمره في قطاع غزه
سنبدا من جنوب القطاع حيث المعارك على
اشدها في اكثر من منطقه في في محافظه
خانيونس والمنطقه الجنوبيه بشكل عام سنبدا
لنقول بان خانيونس ما زالت موقع اشتباك
وايضا خزاعه ما زال
موضع اشتباك او عادت موضع اشتباك بني
سهيله الزنه الى حد اقل تشتبك فيها كتائب
القسام وفصائل المقاومه مع القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
استراتيجيه لكتائب القسام وبالتالي
التركيز الكبير على خزاعه يعود مجددا الى
ال الى الجنوب يترافق هذا بطبيعه الحال مع
قصف وايضا نسف عدد من المواقع خان يونس
اليوم شهدت عمليات نسف نفذتها قوات
الاحتلال لمبان
ومجمعات سكنيه بالتزامن مع ذلك ومنذ صباح
اليوم اندلعت جبهه جديده او اشتعلت الى حد
اعلى جبهه جديده جنوب خانيونس منطقه معا
التي ايضا تتعرض لقصف شديد مدفعي وايضا
احيانا بالطائرات القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي لا يتوقف حتى في المناطق التي
تجري فيها الاشتباكات ولكن بطبيعه الحال
القصف لا يكون حيث تتمركز الالات الاليات
الاسرائيليه لنقرب الفكره اكثر سنستخدم
واحده من الصور هي في الحقيقه لاقمار
الصناعيه هذه ماخوذه من صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز وليست حديثه هي التقطت في ال 26 من
ديسمبر الماضي ولكن فقط لتقريب ما الذي
نعنيه عندما تتحدث عن قصف مكثف هذه منطقه
في منطقه الجنوب هذا هو شارع صلاح الدين
الشارع الاشهر الذي يقطع قطاع غزه من
شماله الى جنوبه
المناطق المضلله هي المناطق المناطق التي
تعرضت لقصف مركز اسرائيلي وعلى مساحات
واسعه كما ترون
المناطق
الاصغر هي مناطق التوغ الاسرائيليه هنا
كانت الدبابات الاسرائيليه لم تدخل بعد
خانيونس هذه المنطقه الى الشرق من حيث
صلاح الدين بمعنى هذه المنطقه هي الجراره
التي دخلتها اولا القوات الاسرائيليه
وتلاحظون حجم الدمار هنا مدينه خانيونس
القوات الاسرائيليه كانت مازالت تحاصر
المدينه لكنها لم تدخل هنا ايضا تمركز
للقوات الاسرائيليه وهنا عمليات قصف مكثفه
وا يبدو واضحا حجم الدمار الذي الحقته ال
قوات الاحتلال ومهدت يعني التعبير العسكري
تمهيد بالنار بالتوازي مع هذا الذي يجري
في الجنوب تشتعل المنطقه الوسطى اليوم
اشتعلت جبهه جديده في الزويده نظرا
للاهميه الجيو استراتيجيه للزو بالمعنى
الميداني ان سيطرت عليها اسرائيل تستطيع
التوغل من الغرب بينما تحاصر المغازي
والبريج من ثلاث جهات والى الشمال ختاما
حيث عادت الاشتباكات وعادت الاستهدافات في
تحديدا اليوم كان هناك استهدافات في
جباليا ومخيم بلده جباليا ومخيم جباليا
واشتباكات عنيفه بين الطرفين كل ذلك يسير
بينما كتائب القسام وسرايا القدس تستهدف
اليات ومشاه وتجمعات للقوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
على مدى اي اكثر من 90 يوما اللواء فايز
الدويري اذا اذا اردنا ان نبدا من الاخر
الان في اي مرحله من المراحل يمكن ان نقول
ان المعارك قد وصلتها وهل ما ينطبق على
الشمال ينطبق على الوسط وعلى الجنوب ايضا
ام هناك اختلافات في طبيعه المعارك
والتوغل وحتى الاهداف
الاسرائيليه يعني الى اي مرحله وصلت حسب
التصنيف جيش الاحتلال وقياداته تحدثوا عن
المرحله الثالثه والتي لم تبدا بعد بصوره
جاده
فقط خطوات في القاطع الشمالي بينما في
القاطع الجنوبي لا لا تزال العمليه مستمره
الان اذا اردنا ان نقيم الوضع بصوره عامه
بدءا من 7 اكتوبر نجد انه كان هناك عمليه
قصف جوي استمر لمده 19 يوم وكان كما يقال
لا يبقي ولا يذر تم تدمير البنى التحتيه
تم تدمير معظم او الحاق في تلك المرحله
الحاق اضرار كبيره بالمستشفيات كان
العمليه كانها مبنيه على حقد من اجل رد
الاعتبار في لان الكرامه الجيش والكيان
هدرت ومسح بها الارض فكانت ليست مقاربه
عسكريه لتحقيق اهداف انما كانت هي اندفاع
بحب الانتقام انتقام بعد ذ ذلك في 26
اكتوبر بدات المرحله الاولى وكانت بدايه
حذره استمرت ثلاثه ايام عمليات جس نبض من
اجل ايجاد نقاط الضعف ولكن بدات العمليه
والعمليه كانت هي تمثل السيناريو الاسوا
لماذا لانه اختار المناطق التي لا يتوقع
ان مقاتلي القسام وبقيه الفصائل وقياسا مع
الحروب السابقه هو وهاجم من الشمال على
طول 12 م وتقدم مع شارع الرشيد بينما كان
المتوقع ان ياتي من جبل الرئيس في قراءتي
الشخصيه انا قلت سياتي مع شارع الرشيد في
تلك الفتره ودخل مع وادي غزه ومن ثم بدا
تطور المعركه واستمرت تقريبا لغايه 27
نوفمبر ف في هذه الفتره استطاع ان يدخل
الى معظم الاحياء الغربيه
ووصل الى ساحه فلسطين ودخل الى الشيخ
رضوان لكن لم يسيطر على اي قطعه ارض بقيت
بيت حانون بيت لاهيه خارج السيطره نعم بعد
ذلك جاءت الهدنه اذا هو في المرحله الاولى
سواء التمهيديه او المعركه البريه الجزء
الاول منها في القاطع الشمالي لانه كانت
المعركه محصوره في القاطع الشمالي كانجا
عسكري لم يقدم اي انجاز عسكري جاءت الهدنه
تم انتهاء الهدنه بعد سبعه ايام بدات
المرحله الثانيه وبدات المرحله الثانيه
كما يقال بالتوازي كانت اكثر توسعا وشراسه
وزخما نعم فبدات في الشمال بصوره مصغره
لكن بماذا بماذا تميزت المرحله الثانيه
ساجيبك اولا غطت القطاع كامل
باستثناء رفح رفح ودير البلح حتى هذه
اللحظه لا توجد اذا هي غطت الجز الرئيسي
الاوسط والجنوبي من القطاع وعاودت الهجوم
في المنطقه الشماليه في القاطع الشمالي من
الجهه الشرقيه التي تجنبته في البدايه
لانه معروف لديهم بان التفاح والشجاع فيها
قوات النخبه او القوات الضاربه نعم
وبالتالي لا يزال القتال الان مستمر في
المنطقه الشماليه لكنه بعد الاعلان عن
التحول للمرحله الثالثه لانه هو لما صارت
الهدنه عمل اعاده التموضع واستغلها كيف
استغلها كان حجم القوه التي تقاتل في تلك
المنطقه ثلاثه فرق مدعومه بالويه النخبه
يعني ثلاثه فرق منظمه عسكريا مدعومه بجولي
وجف عاتي وغيرها الان استفاد من هذه
الهدنه
سحب ثلاثه فرق وابقى على اربعه الويه ابقى
على اربعه الويه فهذه الفرق الثلاثه مع
فرقه الاحتياط العملياتي والاحتياط
الاستراتيجي بواقع خمس فرق دفع بها الى
المنطقه الوسطى
والجنوبيه هجومه بدا في المنطقه الجنوبيه
كان يتوقع ان الارض تخدم العمليات
العسكريه لماذا لانه في الشمال كانت
معضلته مجرد ان طوق مدينه غزه اصطدم
بالمباني المناطق المبنيه فتحولت معركته
مباشره الى معركه مناطق مبنيه لهذا السبب
هو اذا نظرنا الى الخارطه هنا الواقع
الجغرافي مختلف كل كل مناطق مبنيه هذه كل
لكن الكثافه اذا نظرنا الى منطقه بني
سهيلا واذا منطقه خزاعه الفخاري الزنه
عبسان هناك مسافات كبيره جدا قياسا مع غزه
غزه عباره عن كتله من الاسمنت كتله من
الاسمنت غزه كمدينه غزه وبالتالي هناك
كانت معركته معركه مناد مناطق مبنيه
بالمطلق وجرى ما جرى وكانت النتيجه
النهائيه لا يزال يقاتل الان في مناطق
محدوده جدا في اطراف التفاح في اطراف
الشجاعيه في اطراف جبل الريس
و المقاومه في المنطقه الشماليه لا تزال
تبلي بلاء حسنا
واجبرته فتراجع مكرها لا طوعا طيب ماذا
جرى في المنطقه الجنوبيه انفتحت القوات
اعد لها خمسه فرق دفع بثلاثه فرق كان
الهجوم من الشمال من كسوفين باتجاه
القراره و باتجاه المطاحن مدينه الحمد
المواصي حتى وصل الى جوش قطيف لكن هذه
العمليه لم تقدم له الكثير فدفع بقوه
جديده من منطقه الفخاري
وعزز بجهد ثاني من منطقه الزنيه حتى تلتق
القوات القادمه من الزنيه مع القوات
القادمه من الفخاري على شارع صلاح الدين
وتدخل الى
مدينه غزه ماذا جرى العمق مدينه خانيونس
عفوا مدينه خان يونس ماذا جرى القوات التي
دخلت من المنطقه الشماليه من منطقه زنيه
على الحدود الشماليه لعبس الجديده واجهت
مقاومه شرسه جدا ولم تستطع ان تتقدم لا بل
تم اجبارها على التراجع القوات التي قدمت
من الفخاري جنوب خزاعه كذلك واجهت نفس
المشكله ولكن لا تزال متمو في تلك المنطقه
ظهرت مشكله
خزاعه ظهرت مشكله خزاعه تنظيم قواته في
هذه المنطقه مختلف وادارته للمعركه مختلفه
بسبب معطيات كثيره الاختلاف الجوهري
والرئيسي استخدم نظام الانساق بحيث النسق
الاول وصل الى ثمانيه الويه والنسق الثاني
يوجد لوائين فدفع من الويه النسق الثاني
للتعامل مع خزاعه بينما لا تزال الالويه
الاخرى عالقه ولم و قطعت صلاح الدين
تراجعت لكن بدا يجري معارك جانبيه لتسهيل
النجاح ف على سبيل المثال ذهب الى القراره
ويهاجمها الان من ثلاثه مناطق عندما اغلقت
عليه هذه المنطقه ذهب الى الخيار البديل
ذهب الى المنطقه الوسطى كذلك اجر اجرى
تعديل التعديل كان كالاتي دفع بفرقه 36
مدرعه ودفع بلوائي لواء مظلي ولواء من
الويه النخبه وهنا اجرى تغيرا شاملا في
اداره المعركه هذا التغير تمثل بما يسمى
المعركه المشتركه بر بحر جو للمره الاولى
يكون هناك محاولات جاده من اجل عمليات
الابرار او الانزال البحري
على منطقه المواصي ومدينه ام حمد مقابل
خان يونس يضاف الى ذلك بدا يستخدم مقاربه
الامريكيه في العراق وفي سوريا مهاجمه ك
لناخذ الرقه مثالا او الموصل او الفلوجه
كان يهاجمها من كافه الجها الجهات الان
الامريكيين يسموها الموصل دكترين عقيده
الموصل المهاجمه من كافه الجهات ومحاوله
التوغل بمبدا القضم المتدرج هنا لا تتناسب
لانها مجموعه
مناطق فبالتالي عمد الى استغلال الفراغات
نعم وعمل على تح قطع التواصل ما بين هذه
المنطقه لو تعطينا الوسط لو
سمحتي طيب لاحظ الان الان يهاجم البريج من
الجهه الشماليه من الجهه الشرقيه من الجهه
الغربيه يهاجم الصيرات من الجهه الشرقيه
من الجهه الشماليه من الشماليه الغربيه
يهاجم الزوايده من الجهه الغربيه يهاجم
المغازي من الجهه الشرقيه والجنوبيه وهو
دخل في المسافات البينيه لكن دعني اشير
الى نقطه هذه تسمى مناطق رخوه سهل الدخول
لها لكن كانت المناطق الرخوه ليست مناطق
رخوه كانت مناطق
صلبه كان الم
المومون هو لماذا ذهب الى الى المغرا والى
القراره لان المغرا والقرار كانت بداياتها
تذكره بجحر الديك فصارت الضربات المؤلمه
الان تاتي في المناطق الزراعيه المناطق
المفتوحه فدخل في مرحله الارتباك ماذا جر
بعد ذلك الخلاف داخل مجلس الحرب نعم
وبالتالي هذا القى بظلاله لانه الان هناك
هجوم على رئيس الاركان من بن كفير ومن
سموتريش
وغيره عندما تصبح القياده السياسيه ليست
غطاء للعمل العسكري بل م مناكف له القائد
العسكري يصبح مشلول الذهن وغير قادر على
اداره المعركه بنجاح فبعد هذا 92 يوم اذا
سالت ماذا انجز جيش الاحتلال اقول
لك انجز فقط ما يندرج تحت قوانين جرائم
الحرب التدمير التهجير غير ذلك واعطي مثال
تفضل نعم باختصار شديد هذا المثال باختصار
شديد المثال انا شاهدت فيديو لاحد الجنود
يقول بانه قتل طفله عمره 12 عام ولكنه
حزين ليس على قتل الطفله لانه لم يجد رضيع
يقت انظر الى ثقافه هذا الجيش الذي يدعي
الاخلاقيه شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فيز دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي